the economic policy uncertainty index is
a measure of policy uncertainty so how
uncertain people are about what the
government is going to do in the u.s.
going forward so are they uncertain
about taxes about spending about
healthcare regulation and to measure
this we use a combination of how
frequently the newspapers so paper's
like the Wall Street Journal and The New
York Times discuss economic policy
uncertainty we also look at the amount
of tax code about to expire and finally
we look at how much disagreement there
is amongst economic forecasters about
future taxes and spending and when you
combine these three measures into one
index you get our economic policy
uncertainty index the key thing this
shows is a huge increase in policy
uncertainty since 2008 so before then it
was bouncing up and down occasional
spikes from wars and elections and then
suddenly since 2008 one it's gone up
massively and it's now incredibly high
for the last four years
the level really from 08 onwards is
about as high as the height at 2001
after the 911 terrorist attack so that
was an era of incredible uncertainty who
did the terrorist attacks remembering
that you know bin Laden didn't initially
own up to them the anthrax the war in
Afghanistan is such a huge uncertainty
lasting for 23 months that dropped back
down again now we've seen a similar
levels staying that way for four years
because of things like the debt ceiling
dispute tarp healthcare regulation so
really a new high level that's about as
high as we've ever seen before why does
policy uncertainty so high right now I
think you have to go back a bit in time
to understand it so the story is the US
has been slowly running a deficit it's
really spending more than his earned
that was disguised in the mid-2000s
because we had a booming economy and
very high tax take it's kind of like
you're spending more money than he can
afford but you've had bonuses for the
last four years and it's disguised the
fact you're running a deficit suddenly
the booms gone away and it's become
painfully clear we're spending far too
much money compared to what are raising
in taxes so what that's done is forced
attention on to how can we a cut
spending and be put up taxes now the
political parties don't agree on how to
do that the Republicans primarily on a
cut expenditure and the Democrats
primarily want to put up taxes and they
don't agree in there you know innocence
they really don't agree they have really
very polarized opposite opinions and as
they fight between taxes up versus
spending down it generates tremendous
uncertainty in the economy
why does policy uncertainty matter
policy uncertainty generates a slowdown
and the reason is businesses tend to
wait on making expense of hiring in
investment decisions when they're
uncertain so if I'm running let's say
sandwich shop in Palo Alto around you
know in California I'm thinking of
opening up a second branch go making
money but I'm very uncertain I may wait
I may wait to see what happens to policy
next year before I make my decision now
of course if everybody waits to her at
best you have a recession how long will
policy on certain you go on for how long
are we going to see incredible levels of
policy uncertainty my view is this is
going to last for some time and the
reason is the big driver is the fact
that the deficit is in such a mess we
spend so much more than they earn and
that's driven by huge spending on health
care so we look at where America's
spendings going up and up and up it's on
healthcare expenditure and I don't see
that changing very radically so unless
we get health care under control we're
going to keep running deficits and keep
having crisis every few years
you